I'm here with Vlad Ardell on who the CEO
of Superbad Romania and the mastermind
between the organization of this
tournament of La tell us a little bit
about your first experience as a chess
tournament organizer here in vigorous
I'm I'm full of emotion as I'm a chess
player myself I learned to play chess
from my grandfather when I was five and
then I was competing when I was too near
in Romania
so my heart is filled with joy that we
can give back to the chest community
here in Romania and all across the world
a little bit of our support so I'm very
very happy to be the host of
Grantchester in Romania and we are
really looking forward to continue this
event in the next year's and hopefully
this will become a tradition well from
what I'm hearing you guys have plans to
bring it back in 2020 tell us a little
bit about that and how that came to be
well this this is happening because we
have chess in our heart I was a chess
player myself but also the founder of
our group was a professional chess
player in his youth so if we as we are
in a position to redistribute some of
our success to the community
we will start with chess because chess
is something that defined ourselves as
personalities so we are really looking
forward to help the community and do to
promote chess and everything we did here
in Romania like bringing a lot of
awareness in terms of media in terms of
PR so that we are trying to create an
emulation around the chess community we
are also inviting kids to see the Titans
of the global titans of chess here to
play with them to look at them to learn
from them so we are trying to expand the
boundaries of the chess community
the super butt foundation is sponsoring
the grand gesture but it's also
sponsored the younger generation as well
as the romanian federation tell us a
little bit about that and your
partnership with the local community
here so Grantchester
it's a top event and it's an honor for
us to have it here but beyond that we
were always thinking how to expand the
local chess space and local chess
community so our first move since we we
happily been awarded this grant Chester
franchise was to talk to the local
Federation and see what we can do
together with them alongside with this
galvanising big event like ranches tours
so we signed a exclusivity partnership
with a local Federation we are now
supporting the Romanian chess team
throughout the year and of course we are
organizing parallel with Grantchester
event here in Statuary Country Club
the similar tournament for for the top
10 Romanian chess players alongside the
rules and regulations of cran chest or
so that we bring together the local
chess community and the international
chess community so hopefully galvanizing
effect for the furthering chess interest
worldwide a lot of very exciting
projects thank you very much lot for
everything you do and go enjoy the games
now thank you guys
you